hundreds of local small businesses are
in the process of securing work for Las
Vegas's first ever Super Bowl but with
only so many opportunities to go around
8 news now reporter Ryan Matthey
explains how those businesses are also
pitching themselves for work more long
term
Mark Brown has been in the live
entertainment industry for decades man I
love it so much somebody called me right
now I was singing a phone booth what
makes us different what do we have to
offer he started dreamstone Productions
in 2020 to bring DJ's tribute bands and
Headliners to Las Vegas venues there is
never an event football basketball
baseball soccer whatever that you don't
hear music in the background and he
wants to bring that vibe to Las Vegas's
first Super Bowl but opportunities are
limited if not the big game itself he
and other businesses get the opportunity
to pitch themselves for something else
it's really tough for small businesses
to compete with big box 45 of those
small businesses pitching their services
during Allegiant stadiums and the
Raiders Gridiron pitch we're looking for
a little bit of everything new Mia
Duncan Reed with Legion Stadium calls it
a pathway to expand contract potential
either at the stadium in local
government or with other Vegas agencies
but to get an invite they needed to be
accepted into the Super Bowl business
connect program which includes 200 local
minority owned companies if I give you a
project if I give you a contract can you
deliver do you have the staff do you
have the expertise opportunities
potentially spanning far beyond the big
game leaving those pitching with future
prospects any opportunity is better than
zero
as for working the Super Bowl itself
business connect members will get to
meet with NFL vendors for the first time
tomorrow and the big game is nine months
away